what up Sunday morning another biz Devon
Sunday I'm excited just to looks like
he's dead matter away I'm bombing guys
another bag come around that's nice
like a visible attack you would like my
name is daddy stop I've been telling you
accounting faculty I'm trippin to heaven
a pedigree Devine and a pleasure my
faculties are putting the works and I'm
joking are the moving furniture seven
clicks like there's a dead man behind me
just a Novello Brethren lore
extraordinaire
brother-in-law extraordinaire there we
go anyway Joran so guys we'll get into
the biz dev aspects in a second it's
going extremely well a lot of good
action going on and got some good ones
this week so looking forward it here we
go Gary be calm flash are you rock
that's right we because of their talent
and small business position because of
my brand and because of all my
entrepreneurial wants a need of maybe
doing this for other a-list
entrepreneurs of celebrities or
different things outside of an inner
talent world or the next brand I buy in
one week seven-figure businesses I get
into last week and we decide the founder
needs to be the face of the business we
are on a mission to collect more D rocks
Tyler Babb and yes Justin others
Portuguese can dab dominates amazing
they're out there there are tens of
thousands of D rocks in my opinion he's
the best and he's incredible but these
what are called I guess I'm at work
predators P and I want to film add it to
the whole thing
kitten caboodle like you're the whole
production company in one your kids
since seven I've been hacking and mix
and matching YouTube videos you love
damn you know you play you understand
how to make wean videos on Instagram
you're a video production 2017 ninja
predator if you're one of those people
and you want to come and work at our
place entry-level jobs three months
learn it learn it with us learn the
d-roc way learn mid babban way learn the
way dunk sandy and I and the whole world
see it and then spit out and work at
being or talent or small business or in
vaynermedia or
stay on our team because we
so much we are looking for them click
the link below send your message there's
a forum you'll fill it out be smart
about how you fill it out there should
be a lot of entries on this a lot of
people clean to the end Dirac prove it
okay so a bunch of you want your music
on daily be please submit the form
Gary B music 4gb link oi here not well
links in the video description but the
URLs right there bunch of you talking a
lot of [ __ ] on social but you got the
fattest beat prove it to us submit it
looking for a lot more music for daily
be in the future it's a great way hit up
your homies who are in it great way to
get some exposure obviously a lot of
artists have been benefiting this great
great Sunday with the boys wave is dead
Sunday go spend some time with your boys
and girls
[Music]